welcome to the david pakman show i'm
farin cousins i've been sitting in for
david pakman this week
and we have a lot to cover today so
let's go ahead and jump right in
obviously one of the biggest things
happening right now in the country
that's not named joe manchin
is the omicron variant according to the
new numbers the omicron variant now
makes up
73 percent
of new covid cases
and of course with holiday travel
happening right now these are the
numbers from last friday
holiday travel is happening holiday this
weekend we can expect those numbers to
climb even higher and that is why of
course on tuesday
president joe biden once again just like
he did in september came out and
addressed the nation
to both sooth our fears
and remind us
that we can protect ourselves at least
to a certain degree
from this virus
he
just like in september again reiterated
that this is becoming a pandemic of the
unvaccinated
and at this point not getting a booster
shot
is also kind of seen as not being fully
vaccinated we are seeing a drop-off in
efficacy
so if you got your vaccine your first
two doses february march of this year
depending on the vaccine it could be
down to roughly a 40
efficacy
compared to where it was several months
ago if you do not get vaccinated you're
still offered some protection from it
obviously it does of course reduce risk
of hospitalization and death but that is
why those booster shots are so important
these vaccines do not last forever this
mra mrna vaccine
is not a forever thing and
booster shots may be something that we
have to live with
for the foreseeable future
and the biden administration is also
saying we're going to get tests out to
american citizens 500 million tests
they're pledging so that is a step
forward and of course
that is due to pressure
it was only what a week two weeks ago
when jinsaki during a press conference
you know kind of dismissed the idea
of giving the public free covet tests
and now suddenly it's a reality after
everybody pushed back on that issue so
the administration is responding to
pressure
also worth noting but off topic the fact
that now they're even considering
extending
the student loan debt repayments pushing
that back further down the road again
this is due to public pressure
but it all underscores obviously the
bigger point here omicron is running
rampant here in the united states
whereas a handful of weeks ago we had
one case out in california one case in
minnesota
now it's
73.2 percent of all new cases and of
course that number is expected to rise
there's still too much we do not know
about omicron
so again the best advice and this is
what biden is telling us is be safe we
don't have to go into a panic he told us
we're not going back to lockdowns which
i don't know maybe that is something we
should discuss here in the here in
america
we never really had real lockdowns
anyway let's be honest about it we had
50 different states doing 50 different
things
because our federal government then run
by the trump administration
didn't want to do anything
so that's why we got pummeled with covet
in the first year and then of course by
the time biden came back everything was
reopened he didn't want to
send us back to
lockdowns and he still refuses to do
that so
i don't think regardless of how bad it
gets i don't think biden's going to put
us back in that situation anyway even if
we need it
i think he feels kind of like trump did
the optics of that in an election year
probably aren't going to look too great
so
it is what it is
if you're traveling this holiday weekend
protect yourself if you're going to be
around friends family any large group of
individuals indoors
wear masks if you can
socially distance when possible
do what you can to protect yourself
because omicron does appear at least
right now
to be a little more
permeable
in the vaccinated we're not seeing
obviously as severe of symptoms
but it's still a threat so please please
please
protect yourselves out there
and
part of protecting yourself
means protect yourself from the
misinformation and of course the
staggeringly stupid advice
coming from the right
paul gosar has become one of the latest
uh people on the right
to actively encourage people
to fight back against
covet protections
in a video that surfaced this week uh
put out there by ethan schmidt who runs
the so-called anti-masters club
so you know right off the bat with the
name there you can tell super serious
organization
got a video of gosar
and gosar said this hey here's to that
anti-vaxxer group
stay the course
and then schmidt replies yeah
anti-vaxxer club
stay the course he's telling the
anti-vaxxers
the people who are actively telling the
rest of the country to not get the
vaccine
stay
the course
omicron is 73 percent of new cases
across the country that graph is once
again making another swing
this is what the fifth sixth wave
of covid we are now experiencing
in this yahoo
who serves in congress
has a medical degree
is telling people
listen to the anti-vaxxers don't give up
your anti-vaxx ways i mean that's what
stay the course means
it means keep doing what you're doing
keep spreading misinformation paul
is that what you want them to be doing
because the statistics also show that
not only is coveted rising but
it's rising faster in areas that voted
for donald trump which means it's rising
faster among republicans
we also know that
far more republicans are unvaccinated
than democrats
to put it another way you're killing
your base
as i mentioned earlier on this week's
program being a republican is basically
a comorbidity with covet at this point
and their own lawmakers members of their
own party are actively telling them
keep it keep it up keep doing it you're
you're killing them
you're actively killing them
much like sarah palin suggested you know
at the turning point usa conference you
know oh you keep fighting back we don't
need this shot i'll get the shot over my
dead body
sarah palin says
encouraging others to not
do the bare minimum
to protect themselves
and at some point
if people like gosar and palin of course
continue saying these things we're going
to have to have a real conversation
ahead of the midterms
about what the mortality rate of covid
has done to the american electorate
and i know that's a rather morbid
conversation that a lot of people are
avoiding but but that's something we do
have to talk about
because again for months now this has
been primarily a republican
centric
disease
only about 10 percent of democrats
self-identified democrats say they're
not vaccinated
almost 40 percent of republicans say
they're not
and
we're almost seeing the same kind of
ratio
in the death totals for covid
they're actively killing their base
they're giving them this horrendous
advice
that is killing
them so how is that going to play out in
the midterms it is going to have an
impact
so again
that's a tough conversation it's
certainly an unpleasant conversation
but it's one that we're going to have to
have in the coming year and maybe we
need to have the conversation sooner
look i'm obviously on the left right i
have my politics on the left
but that doesn't mean that i want to see
anyone
on the right die from this virus i don't
want to see any human being die from
this virus again
if i could stop it right now if we had a
magic wand i would do it i wasn't i
wouldn't hesitate even you know
we have to put the politics aside but
in order to do that
we have to be able to convince
the people on the other side
that they have to care about this that
they have to take care of themselves
so maybe it is time to have those
conversations about republicans killing
off their base and what that's going to
do to their election chances because i
guarantee you
if they look at those voting rolls
and see that they've lost enough voters
that could have swung an election in
previous years
they're going to change their tune
they're suddenly going to realize oh
wait a minute you know what maybe mass
are good
maybe
maybe people ought to get vaccinated
so it is time for those conversations if
for no other reason
than to scare republican politicians
into finally doing the right thing
and encouraging their base to protect
themselves
and another thing another thing that
needs protecting
is apparently dr anthony fauci
jesse waters
fox news host
came out recently
and said the following
this is at the turning point usa
conference again this is you know where
all the wackos love to go so he said
this this is where you say dr fauci you
funded risky research at a sloppy
chinese lab the same lab that sprung
this pandemic on the world that's not
true
you know what people don't trust you
you know what people don't trust you
don't you okay maybe that's a typo
boom he is dead he is dead he's done you
do that 30 seconds it's all you need
get us that that's what we want
that changes the whole conversation
of the country
now waters
was suggesting that people as he put it
ambush
dr fauci if they ever see him in public
but the
boom he is dead he is dead he's done
get us that that's what we want
to me
to my ears
that sounds like a death threat
that sounds like a fox news host calling
for his supporters to
possibly kill dr anthony fauci
and of course to somebody like fauci
that's also apparently how it sounded
because fauci has now said this guy
should have been fired on the spot
fox news as of uh
this show has not released a comment
about jesse waters statement here
and of course
there's other ways to interpret that if
you were actually going to try to
convict him
on this you wouldn't win that case and
here's why
because dead can actually have multiple
meanings he's dead
could mean his career is dead could mean
his argument is dead he was vague enough
with what he said
to not get prosecuted for it
but that doesn't excuse it
and here's the thing fauci also pointed
this out in his response where he said
water should be fired on the spot he
said they're not so much mad at me and
fighting against me as they're fighting
against science
because that is what is happening right
now
these republicans are fighting against
science
because science is against them
apparently
but that's a position that they took
they decided
to make science their enemy they decided
to make science the antithesis of what
they stand for they didn't have to do
that
this was a conscious effort made by the
republican party that has spanned
several decades now
you know they're on the wrong side of
science on the issue of climate change
they're on the wrong side of science you
know social sciences
when it comes to
things like trickle down theory
when it comes to
helping the poor
and of course with the pandemic itself
as well
they're always on the opposite side of
this
and that is what they're mad at but most
importantly
they know how badly republicans have
screwed this up
so fauci has become their punching bag
and their fall guy
so they can blame him
instead of acknowledging all of their
failures
over the past two years
i'm farron cousins in for david pakman
you can find me on social media twitter
facebook and instagram at fair and
balanced and of course youtube.com slash
the ring of fire we'll be right back
with
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpackman.com
and use the coupon code better21
for a huge discount join pacman.com
welcome back to the david pakman show i
am fair and cousins sitting in for david
pakman you can find me on youtube at
fair
youtube.com
balanced and youtube dot com slash the
ring of fire and of course every week i
hope host the ring of fire podcast go to
rofpodcast.com
well we've got more coveted news to talk
about and it actually calls back to a
story we talked about yesterday as
you'll recall
we showed the clip of donald trump and
bill o'reilly their little rewrite
history tour
where donald trump sheepishly admitted
that he had in fact gotten the coveted
booster
the crowd booed him they did not want to
hear that
and then
bill o'reilly this week does an
interview with dan abrams on news nation
and o'reilly admits
to abrams that he had to console trump
after that crowd booed him after the
event of course they weren't on stage
when the
you know
make him feel better part took place
so here's what o'reilly said
i told him that today he called me
uh
he was hurt by their reaction i said
this is good for you this is good that
people see another side of you not a
political side you told the truth you
believe in the facts your administration
did it
and you should take credit for it
because it did save i don't know
hundreds of thousands of lives
so i'm just picturing this scenario in
my head right
because this wasn't even like backstage
after the event that o'reilly had to go
up to and be like hey bud you okay no
this was like the next day
trump calls him
and raleigh is probably like oh god
yeah hello
i'm still so sad they they were so mean
to me
yeah bud um listen hey
sometimes it's okay sometimes it happens
now listen as i said yesterday i'm
actually okay with donald trump claiming
he created the vaccines whatever it
takes to get these people vaccinated at
this point right
but at the same time
you did this
i mean you you were the only one who
didn't appear in that you know psa with
some of the other former presidents who
encouraged people to get vaccinated
you've openly expressed your disdain
for wearing masks like you're literally
encouraging your followers to not
protect themselves
even in your little diatribe that we
talked about you still said if you don't
want to get it don't get it no mandates
no
mandates you're driving them
to this
so you don't get to be upset
when
your little frankenstein's monster
turns on its creator
and that is exactly what happened here
the the q people out there
they're now confused and
a little angry because they don't know
how to feel about trump because suddenly
he's he's promoting the vaccine so rest
assured we're going to end up with a new
conspiracy theory in the next couple
days as to why trump really
claimed to have been boosted
so i guarantee you that's on the horizon
so be on the lookout for that but again
you made this possible
by downplaying the pandemic
by suggesting it was overblown by
repeatedly telling us last year that oh
it's going to be gone soon oh
everything's going to be fine
and then of course not encouraging
people to get vaccinated hiding your own
vaccination status
from people
that drives them
to these horrible horrible decisions
and of course contributed to their
anti-vaxx ideology
believe it or not that was not even the
weirdest thing that o'reilly said
during that interview with dan abrams
he goes on to say
i'm trying to tell president trump run
on your record
he's going to run again all right
so bill o'reilly who clearly is in close
contact with donald trump has spent
several weeks with him has spent other
time with him throughout this year tells
us that without a doubt donald trump is
running for president in 2024
so that's something we also have to deal
with something that also has to be
addressed
but
to his statement run on your record what
record is that
400 000 dead americans in a pandemic
that you pretended wasn't a big deal
a trade war with china
that you had no idea what the end goal
was you just started it because you were
i don't know feeling a little weird that
day
or is it your border wall
that's sitting down there literally
falling apart washing away and rusting
this is about the only three things oh
i'm sorry tax cuts
you also cut taxes for the wealthy and
screwed over working class people by
taking away some of our deductions
what else
i mean for real what else was donald
trump's record here
so bill when you tell him run on your
record
you got to be a little more specific
than that because there's only a handful
of things the guy did and all of them
are bad
right there's no good thing
when you look at it from a purely
non-partisan political
analysis
what good thing happened during the
trump administration are there truly any
people in this country who can look at
that and say oh my life is better off
today
at the end of his administration than it
was at the beginning he did something
that made me better of course
the top 10 percent of income earners
sure they can say that 100 percent
but the rest of the country no we can't
say that
there was either no change or it got
worse and of course with the pandemic it
got worse for everybody
except the billionaires
so i don't know that encouraging him to
run on his record is the smartest thing
unless of course you want him to lose
which i do so yes please run on your
record and remind people how horrible
those four years were
now some people are probably thinking no
fair and he did have an accomplishment
he packed the courts with republican
hacks and i'm going to counter you on
that and say that was not necessarily
trump that was mitch mcconnell that
would have happened under any republican
president
mitch mcconnell would have made that
happen so no i do not count that as a
trump thing i count that as a mcconnell
thing and i know trump would probably be
furious to hear people say that
but hey that's the reality under which
we live today
believe it or not though there's even
more stupidity out there this time
coming from not the former people at fox
news like bill o'reilly but the current
people
on fox and friends on tuesday carly
shimkas
decided to offer one of the most idiotic
takes
on why people should not
get the covid vaccine
she said this and this was actually they
were talking about the clip of trump and
o'reilly uh because apparently you know
slow do's week it's one of the biggest
things so she said this good for him
everybody should have the option to make
up their own mind about this about 74 75
percent of americans are at least
partially vaccinated that's a high
number
if you look at the reality of the
situation if somebody isn't vaccinated
right now and they look at their two
friends who between the three of them
had six shots against covid and they
still got it because of omicron
realistically that person isn't going to
get vaccinated
so she's telling people
that because you can still get these
breakthrough infections which yes
they're becoming more common
that you just shouldn't get vaccinated
right oh well they're vaccinated and
they still got it
so why would i bother getting vaccinated
well i don't know maybe because those
three people aren't dead
and here's the thing we're seeing more
breakthrough infections right now
because as i mentioned earlier in this
program the efficacy of the vaccines
does deteriorate over time and
unfortunately what we're seeing with
these covid19 vaccines the deterioration
is taking place over the course of about
six to nine months
you know relatively quickly i mean
that's about the half-life that we're
seeing off of these vaccines so
let me read i went through i compiled a
bunch of statistics here so let me read
this
just to counter her point
that you shouldn't get vaccinated if
you're going to get sick anyway
one large ongoing study of 780 000
veterans shows all three vaccines being
used in the u.s provide strong
protection against death from covet 19
even as their efficacy against mild and
asymptomatic infection fell off
dramatically
researchers looking at men and women
getting treatment at veterans health
administration facilities found that
overall vaccine efficacy against all
types of infection fell from 87.9 in
february to 48 percent
in october they only counted fully
vaccinated veterans and these were done
via pcr tests
unvaccinated patients this is from
november
accounted for 91 of coven 19 deaths
and nearly 94
of those with a combined need for
ventilators or death
that's according to the journal of
american
of the american medical association
again from just last month so
does the vaccine prevent you from
getting sick does it prevent you from
having a breakthrough infection
not necessarily you are still capable of
getting sick
even if you've been vaccinated and
boosted at this point
does it reduce your chances of getting
sick heck yeah
does it reduce your chances of dying
from covet 19 or even being put on a
ventilator oh double heck yeah
that's what these numbers tell us 91 of
deaths are unvaccinated
94 percent of deaths slash people on
ventilators unvaccinated
so if getting these shots knocks you
down
into a less than 10 percent chance
of being one of the people who die from
this disease
would you not take that
would you not accept that risk when you
know what's waiting on the other side
and that is the part that people like
carly schemkes conveniently leave out of
their arguments
you know oh well people can still get
sick sure they can still get sick
you can still get the flu even if you've
had a flu shot
but you're less likely to get it as
severe
if you've had the vaccine and it's the
same thing with covid
what we're trying to do at the moment in
addition to slow the spread which let's
face it as a country we're really really
bad at that
we're trying to prevent more death
we're trying to prevent
long-term injury you know the long
haulers they call them
i have some in my family
that had covered months ago
they still can't even climb a flight of
stairs without getting winded and having
to sit down
we don't know yet
how severely
this virus is going to continue to
impact people year after year
and i'm not just talking about new waves
and new infections i'm talking about the
people who had the severe cases
and in the case of my family they didn't
end up on ventilators luckily they
didn't get that far
so this was just hospitalization from a
severe case that didn't quite get as
severe as some others
and this story is not unique uh new
orleans saints coach sean payton
it took him over two months
to get over his covet infection in the
early part of last year
and of course he recently was
re-diagnosed with covet again
but we're seeing these long-haulers the
people with these long-term issues and
and we don't even have enough time
yet under our belts
to fully understand
how bad it is going to affect these
people is it going to wear off in about
a year the effects of this they'll be
back to normal
or is this going to be a persistent
problem that opens them up to other
breathing complications in the future
other lung ailments
we don't know yet
so for all those people out there who
say oh we don't know what's in the
vaccines you don't know what's in
mountain dew either
but you have no problem guzzling that
down
but more importantly
you don't know what the long-term
effects of covet are going to be on your
body
and i think it's a heck of a lot safer
to trust these vaccines
than to trust that this virus isn't
either going to kill you
or permanently damage your lungs
to where your life is forever altered
i think that's a pretty easy gamble
to take on the vaccines
i am farron cousins in for david pakman
you can find me on social media twitter
facebook instagram at fair and balanced
we'll be right back
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com david pakman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos the daily bonus show
the commercial free daily show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies
mugs and t-shirts you can support the
show for as little as two dollars a
month
check it out at patreon.com david pakman
show welcome back to the david pakman
show i am fair and cousins sitting in
for david pakman this week um we do have
to talk about joe manchin i know we've
talked about him every day this week but
obviously as the week has progressed
more and more stuff has happened and one
of those things happens to be actress
bette midler
now what happened
with the bette midler you're asking well
if you've been on social media i'm sure
you've seen it
bette midler and i guess you would call
it a fit of anger
about joe manchin excuse me
tanking build back better
sent out a tweet that she later
apologized for so here's the original
tweet
what joe manchin who represents a
population smaller than brooklyn has
done to the rest of america who wants to
move forward not backward like his state
is horrible he sold us out
he wants us all to be just like his
state west virginia poor illiterate
and strung out and
dang it if you hadn't added
that last sentence
probably would have been okay but
obviously
it's not fair
to attack an entire state in this
country all the citizens of it
for the actions of the man they continue
to send to the senate
you know what
i kind of understand it i truly do
and uh
of course as i mentioned midler then
came out apologized for it here's her
apology tweet i apologize to the good
people of west virginia for my outburst
i'm just seeing red joe manchin his
whole family or a criminal enterprise is
he really the best west virginia has to
offer its own citizens surely there's
someone
someone there who has the state's
interests at heart not his own
good enough apology right i'm okay with
that in fact to be honest
i'm not even mad at bette medler for the
original tweet and that may give me some
hate i understand
it's not something i would have said
in my younger years actually i probably
would have said something like that
but no was it was it fair probably not
and of course some of the things she
said actually weren't even that accurate
illiterate no
west virginia is actually 16th
lowest literacy rate in the country
the top four states are california new
york florida and texas
because the larger the population
the larger the likelihood that you have
more illiterate citizens so west
virginia is not even in the top 10
in most illiterate states so that was
that was a low blow that was also
factually inaccurate
the other points though poverty they got
the sixth highest poverty rate in the
country
31st in unemployment so not too bad
right they get a 6.3 unemployment rate
based on the numbers i saw
so well above the national average but
of course certainly not at the top not
at the bottom just kind of right there
in the middle
one
area however
is what should scare the hell out of
west virginians and this is something
especially with the environmental
provisions from buildback better that
needs to be hit on repeatedly
the cancer rate in west virginia
is the 48th
highest
in the nation the highest of course
being kentucky
but that cancer rate
is due partially to the industrial
pollution it's due
to the coal mining operations
in west virginia
but the industrial pollution in west
virginia is well documented i happen to
work with mike papentonio who has
handled multiple environmental lawsuits
in west virginia
where people left and right have been
poisoned by mega corporations for
decades
and the poisons the toxins they've
dumped into these rivers and and streams
and into the environment itself
is still causing cancer to this day
that hasn't gone away
and as long as people like joe manchin
fight back against environmental
protections you're going to continue to
see these very high cancer rates so
those are the kinds of things really
that bette midler should have hit upon
of course i understand she didn't have
time
she she's not a political researcher
she's not involved
in political media in any way so she she
spoke from the heart and sometimes when
you do that
you say things that you really ought not
say and of course you loop in
and blame people
and
basically make fun of them for things
that aren't true and it's not fair
the people of west virginia absolutely
deserve better than joe manchin
but at the end of the day they keep
sending him back to the senate
you know just like the people of
kentucky deserve better than rand paul
and mitch mcconnell yet mitch
mcconnell's been sent back to the senate
since i was two years old
rand paul not quite as long but if he
stays in politics i promise you he will
be
it's just the nature of the beast right
people want to stick with what's
comfortable with what they know
because they aren't afraid that their
lives are going to get better at this
point i think that's never a possibility
or i think they think it's not a
possibility they're just worried their
lives could get worse with somebody
different so that's what we have to fix
that's what we have to address with
these people these residents in these
areas that keep electing horrible people
like joe manchin
we need to explain to them that there
are better options that sometimes
it's okay to take that risk
and vote for somebody you don't know
whose name isn't familiar
joe manchin obviously well known
throughout west virginia
more well-known across america today
than i'm sure manchin ever wanted to be
so that's up to us to educate these
people to help them understand that they
deserve better
and they can have
better
look at it this way
joe manchin blocking build back better
is of course
harmful to the very citizens that he
represents in west virginia
but it's harmful to the entire united
states as well
goldman sachs came out they revised
their economic outlook for the year 2022
had to revise it down
based on joe manchin's statement
they've also told us that
killing this bill is going to starve the
united states economy next year of 60
billion
dollars 60 billion dollars
first quarter gdp growth for next year
was revised down from three percent to
two percent a full percentage point
in terms of gdp
that's a relatively big deal
for one man's vote on one piece of
legislation
that's how powerful he is
he shouldn't be
there's absolutely no reason joe manchin
should have this power
and that of course is what sets people
like bette midler off it sets all of us
off
so
while i don't agree
necessarily
with
how she said
what she said
i do understand it to a degree and of
course she did apologize
so i have no problem with this she did a
good job there
but we shouldn't focus on oh she screwed
up no
we should focus on the anger that she
has and understand that that is not
limited to bette midler
we're all angry
every one of us
but we need to turn that anger into
action
we need to turn the anger into education
we need to help people understand
because look
i'm in florida i don't get to vote for
joe manchin i will never vote for joe
manchin ever in my life
even if i did live in west virginia
but it's still up to us to let people
know
you deserve better and you can have
better
you just have to take that gamble
on a name that's not familiar to you and
trust me folks that is so hard to
convince people to do
but the country may not have much of a
choice
so we have to
and
democrats
came out after of course all the
spotlight's been on joe manchin this
week
and said we're going to play hardball
with him next year
yep
joe biden president joe biden says he is
not done with his talks with joe manchin
this isn't over they're going to
continue on with this chuck schumer says
we're going to play hardball
with joe manchin
we're gonna make this thing happen
and they're gonna start putting pressure
on him
and that's what's been needed this whole
time i want everybody to think for a
second
in terms of in the senate
who are the people you have seen
publicly come out
and call out joe manchin who are sitting
in the senate today well not today
they're on vacation but you know what i
mean
who
chuck schumer has
bernie sanders has
pretty sure elizabeth warren
has it's three
it's three out of three out of 50
that i know of
now that's not to say they're the only
three
sure plenty of other folks could have
flown under the radar maybe their
statements their comments didn't quite
get the attention that the comments of
these other folks had
but why
and bernie sanders made headlines for a
day and a half last week by saying joe
manchin and kirsten sinema were acting
like republicans
but part of the pressure campaign that
has to be put on joe manchin the hard
ball the democrats say they're going to
play
means that it can't just be bernie
sanders they can't just send bernie out
to be the attack dog and then later on
be like well he's not really a democrat
so that's why he can do it no
bernie sanders is more of a democrat
than joe manchin could ever hope to be
in his life trust me
in fact he's more of a democrat than any
of the democrats in that synod but
either way
you can't just have one guy you can't
have three people
elizabeth warren is tough she is
absolutely
just an attack person
and a passionate person and i love
elizabeth warren
but that's also not enough
there has to be this united front
and that's what the democratic party has
been lacking
you know sure you're not gonna get
cinema to join in on the attacks on joe
manchin to to really pressure him you're
not gonna get
tester to do it either
but you can get a handful
you know 10 to 15 other
democratic senators to band together
and go public with this and that's what
you have to do
it can't just be one guy doing an
interview here elizabeth warren doing an
interview over here and you know making
passing comments about joe manchin and
both of them and then the interviewer
moves on to something else that's not
good enough
it has to be press conferences
it has to be meetings
and then after the meetings you have to
do another press conference and talk
about how he wouldn't
go along with what you needed and how
much that's going to harm the people of
the united states
those are the points you hit on
you don't just talk about oh everybody's
going to suffer by this no say listen
because of this man obstructing this
legislation you don't get that child tax
credit money in your bank every month
anymore
because of his decision here we're not
going to have
child care expenses paid for for you
we're not going to have lower cost
prescription prescription drugs we're
not going to have the 35 insulin that's
a part of the legislation
we're not going to transition to
renewable energy we're going to keep
burning the dirty fossil fuels
that's the message you go forward with
but you have to go forward with it
with as united of a front as you can put
together
it can't be a piecemeal patchwork of one
senator over here on msnbc saying it one
on cnn saying it and then nobody talks
about it for another month
no and you can't put it all on joe biden
either
it can't just be mansion and biden
talking again no
it has to be everybody everywhere every
time all the time
going after him and playing hardball so
again the democrats say
they're going to play hardball with joe
manchin in 2022 and i am here for it all
day long
but you have to do it right
you can't just come across as a bunch of
bullies who are mad at mansion
put the real pressure on him remind the
public of what's at stake
and eventually if you're united and
strong
you might just be able to crack him
i'm fern cousins you can find me on
youtube at youtube.com fair and balanced
youtube.com the ring of fire and ring of
fire podcast at rofpodcast.com
i'll be right back with more on the
david pakman show
follow us on social media interact with
the david pakman show community see
exclusive content see when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
big show announcements we post daily
find us on reddit twitter instagram
facebook discord and tick tock
welcome back to the david pakman show i
am fair and cousin sitting in for david
pakman today and hey don't forget you
can find me on all my social media
accounts twitter facebook and instagram
same name on all of them at
farren
balanced that is also the name of my
personal youtube channel and of course
you can find me at youtube.com the ring
of fire
let's talk about the january 6 select
committee to round out this day's show
right
after all
it now appears they're going after
sitting republican members of congress
they submitted a request this week to
republican congressman scott perry and
perry made headlines recently when it
was revealed that he was one of the
i guess you'd call it a ringleader
of some of the other house republicans
who were working to get the doj
to intervene and overturn the results of
the 2020 presidential election scott was
kind of the ringleader
and now mr perry
after
the committee said we would like some
documents from you and of course we
would like for you to sit down and have
a chat with us
has announced that no
not gonna do it
because he says
the committee is somehow illegitimate
and unconstitutional
let me read this statement that perry
put out on tuesday
after deciding he was not going to
work with the committee
i stand with immense respect for our
constitution the rule of law and the
americans i represent who know that this
entity is illegitimate and not duly
constituted under the rules of the u.s
house of representatives
i decline this entity's request and will
continue to fight the failures of the
radical left who desperately seek
distraction from their abject failures
of crushing inflation a humiliating
surrender in afghanistan and the
horrendous crisis they created at our
border
sometimes folks sometimes
there's so much stupid
in one statement
that it hurts it hurts us to read these
things
it's painful
to have those words come out of my mouth
even if they're not from me they're from
him i don't like that at all
so
let's address a couple things real quick
here from mr perry
you're calling the democrats losers
you're saying they can't get over
something dude the reason they want to
talk to you in the first place is
because you tried to overturn the
election you tried to weaponize the
department of justice
to do your bidding and illegally
unconstitutionally by the way since you
seem to love the constitution
overturn the duly elected government of
the united states at the time so you
don't get to lecture anyone about what
is and is not
constitutional
and of course yes the select committee
is 100 percent constitutional that was
actually something i had discussed in
yesterday's program as well
you know with alex jones lawsuit saying
the committee is not constitutional no
it is
courts have ruled over the years yes the
house of representatives does in fact
have this authority uh going all the way
back to the first
uh basically criminal inquiry i guess
you could call it that the house
conducted all the way back in 1795.
so
learn your history scott perry
learn your supreme court cases
congressman perry
so that you won't make such a damn fool
of yourself in the future
but it is what it is right mr perry's
doing what he knows he's worried he's
panicked he understands that the text
messages that have already come out from
him are really really bad and the
committee is doing what they should be
doing and now officially focusing on
these members of congress
the problem
that i have
with them going after these members of
congress because let's not forget jim
jordan
is also involved in this uh gomert
brooks
all of these people do need to be
investigated they do need to be called
in front of the committee but that's not
enough heck we also need to find out why
lauren bobert was you know live-tweeting
nancy pelosi's
location during all of this
she'd only been a member of congress for
at that point really a matter of hours
so why was she doing that so that also
needs to be brought up in front of the
committee the problem i have
is that that's not good enough
just bringing these people in front of
the committee getting your hands on
these records you know their call logs
text messages whatever it is and getting
their testimony
we've seen
a lot of this already
the problem is even if you get horrible
information on any of these individuals
the most you can do is recommend
criminal charges for them you're not
going to vote to expel them
and even if you attempted to vote to
expel them you wouldn't have the votes
to do it
that's what drives me crazy about all of
this
because these members of congress do
need to be expelled
it is time for that
yes we can go through due process we'll
make sure it's all fair and neat you
know cross our t's dot our eyes all of
that
but if you ask me personally right now i
think these people need to be expelled
i think their actions based on the text
messages that again are already readily
available
i think they rise to sedition i think
they rise to treason
we are talking about elected members of
congress
trying to convince the department of
justice to overturn
what effectively was the government
elect
of the united states
there's no ifs hands or buts about it
really when you look at it that way
that would constitute treason
even trying to tell them
to do these things
would likely rise to the level of
sedition
so how are these people still serving in
congress
and the answer is
the republicans
if the democrats had the numbers
i would like to think they would go
ahead and vote to expel these members
right i'd like to think that
heaven only knows sometimes what the
democrats are actually going to do
but without those republican numbers
it's not going to happen
without enough republicans standing up
and saying this person is so toxic
not just to my party
but to the country itself and i believe
that their behavior does rise to the
level of criminal activity and i want
them gone without enough republicans to
say that
it's not going to happen
and then of course maybe
we get charges referred
from this and then maybe
these people get prosecuted and maybe
they get convicted
at this point we're talking about four
or five years out into the future
probably at that point
you know they can serve another what
two and a half terms
in the amount of time that may take
think of the damage that these
individuals could do in that time
it's not good enough
letting them sit there while this
happens is not good enough at the very
least we need some kind of mechanism to
where they could at least be suspended
and i know there is currently no
mechanism like that in the house
maybe that's something we work on maybe
that's an amendment to the constitution
maybe we throw that in with the term
limit
amendment that i also feel we
desperately need
but until this matter is settled until
these people cooperate and turn over
everything and the committee finishes
its work and issues its final report
these individuals should have their
votes suspended
they should be stripped of their
committees immediately
and that should be that
that's what we should do
but again there's no constitutional
mechanism for that to happen so we need
an amendment
to give congress the authority to do
that i believe i don't think they could
just change their own rules to do that
so that's what needs to happen
but let me tell you something else the
most important thing
that needs to happen and this is the
final thing i want to talk about on
today's show
today's main show
and that is
that i think this january 6 select
committee the riot committee whatever
you want to call it
they're now in over their heads
i do not think this committee
as it is right now
should be the lead investig
investigatory body
into the capitol riot
i believe that it is time for merrick
garland to finally step up
and appoint a special prosecutor
to officially start a criminal
investigation
into these events
now don't get me wrong
so far for the most part i have been
very happy with what the select
committee has done
and the reason i say they're in over
their heads
is because of the sheer scope
of what it is they're trying to do
which to be honest we don't even really
know everything they're attempting to do
yet
so you know we have to contend with that
you know they've got trump out there
they say oh we may be looking at
criminal activity here we may be looking
at criminal activity with these
individuals we got roger stone we got
steve bannon now we got members of
congress
and they can't
even if they're from opposing parties
heck almost especially if they're from
opposing parties
they now really can't
do this in a non-partisan way
because you do have lawmakers that do
have to answer these questions they
absolutely have to
that's why a special prosecutor is now
needed convene a grand jury
and essentially take it over for the
most part
because
the optics are always going to be bad
if you have a democrat-controlled
committee
subpoenaing republican members of
congress republicans are going to
weaponize that to show that oh the whole
thing is a partisan sham look they're
going after our lawmakers because this
is so ridiculous
even though there's legitimate reason to
go after them
a special prosecutor could avoid that
to a degree they're still going to claim
it's partisan witch hunt
but the bigger problem
is the longevity of this committee
this committee is not going to be able
to wrap up this investigation by the
midterms
they're just not
and if they do wrap up before then
then they've cut corners in a lot of
places and it's not a complete
investigation
special prosecutor avoids that problem
because what happens when republicans
win back the house if they win back the
house
they kill the committee it's over they
disband it
and what happens if members of the
committee don't win re-election
well then you're in for a real big
problem too
a special prosecutor appointed by the
attorney general avoids all of those
problems
the republicans wouldn't be able to
squash a special prosecutor we've seen
him try trust me we have
but they weren't successful with it
so that's what needs to happen now
but one hundred percent of that rests
upon the shoulders of attorney general
merrick garland who has apparently just
made it clear he's not going to do
anything
and for the record part of the reason
why i say that there's no way this
committee can even wrap things up by the
midterms or even by next january when
the new congress would be sworn in steve
bannon doesn't even go on trial for
contempt until july
okay you're not going to have resolution
for that um
mark meadows hasn't even been arrested
yet
so he'll be arrested arraigned
and then they'll set a trial which will
likely be even further out from july so
you're not going to get the cooperation
you need from these people
probably until after the election
because if they lose the cases they're
going to appeal
so this committee is doomed from the
start because of the way congress itself
is set up
but you avoid those problems
a lot of them disappear completely
if the thing is handed over to a special
prosecutor
or multiple special prosecutors
you know appoint several there's really
no limit to how many you could appoint
to handle each different aspect of that
the rally organizers could be one focus
of one prosecutor the trump
administration could be another the
members of congress could be another and
then of course all the outside players
who weren't with the rally they weren't
with the administration or congress you
know your bannons
um uh
your fox news hosts
who have been texting with mark meadow
all of those other individuals could
fall into another one so there you go
but anyway listen we're out of time for
today's show i'm farin cousins find me
on social media at farron balanced we've
got a wonderful bonus show coming up for
you today including roger stone
flip-flopping on what actually caused
the capital riot i'm farin cousins and
for david pakman thanks